what's going on guys the spoilers for my
academia chapter 289
have just come out and it has defied
expectations in a big way
sugaraki proves his status as the
world's most resilient cockroach
as he just won't take a breather even
after afo told him to retreat
in the last chapter as usual i'll be
doing a breakdown of the fully
translated chapter in a few days
which is always more detailed in these
spoiler reviews so make sure you hit
that sub button
so you don't miss that okay so the
chapter kicks off
with negere and eda heading towards the
main battlefield where shigaraki
is located she questions why eda is
following her
because only flying heroes were supposed
to visit the main battlefield because of
shiguraki's decay quirk
anyone who can't fly is pretty much
screwed if he decides to use it
and back in chapter 274 endeavour
requested that
only heroes who can fly come to assist
him despite that ida felt it was his
duty to go
because deku bakugou and todoroki are
all there
and at this moment he has no idea if
they're okay because shiguraki destroyed
their communication system
as a random side note both mirio and
tamaki have had
big moments in this series before and
negerei is the only member of the big
three without one of these
i mean yeah she's had some smaller wins
here and there but maybe now that she's
about to enter the fray
it's time for her to get this type of
win or she could just die but i prefer
not to think about that outcome
moving on we see deku falling from the
sky and todoroki comes to the rescue yet
again
to save midoriya i need you to
appreciate how much shoto is doing right
now
he's holding back ago in his left hand
holding endeavour in his right arm
and then he's balancing deku on his back
i mean whilst flying
with only one leg is there nothing he
cannot do
once they land on the ground we see that
everyone is still alive for now
although bakugou has blood around his
mouth and no one is actually responsive
shoto starts to access the uh the first
aid kit in his belt
and in the background we see that
shiguraki who
he was falling down in the last chapter
but out of nowhere
he activates the force quirk activation
tentacles
and uses a bunch of them to just suspend
himself in the air
like i said afo specifically told him in
the last chapter
to retreat and recover and get his body
to full health but
shiggy defies those orders and basically
says he's not listening
when the chapter comes out you'll see it
but once again shigoraki has a twisted
evil expression on his face which maybe
indicates that his mission to take one
for all
may not be over just yet at this moment
nederei and ida both arrive on the
battlefield and shoto asks eda
to take deku and bakugo out of there
this is probably a good idea because
i do not know what tenya intends to do
against shigeraki i mean his quirk is
very close range
you know it's just not a good idea for
tenure to engage shigaraki at this
moment
we see nejri unleash our quirk in
shiguraki's direction
and shoto notices that the villain is
looking a lot weaker
than before the scene then pans over to
ochako and toga
and these guys were not on the
battlefield but instead they were in the
suburbs of jakku city
toga had her pinned down in the last
chapter but in this one we see
that uroraka manages to push toga off
her body
and sends the villain flying sideways
toga tries to express her feelings
and says that she always wants to
transform into the person she likes
before revealing something that ochako
did not want to hear
back in my villain academia as i'm sure
you all remember togo used uroraka's
blood
to turn herself into ochako
and then proceeded to use the gravity
quirk to kill someone
in the present day ochako has a
horrified expression
upon hearing this news and she tries to
apprehend toga with the wires in her
costume
toga dodges this and then fires back
with some syringes
that appear to miss but from the leaked
panels it's unclear if they managed to
scrape ochako because if if they scraped
her
then maybe toga did get some blood the
scene ends
with toga stealing the almighty keychain
that deku gave to achako
before asking her if midoriya is the
person that she likes
as usual ochako does not directly answer
that question
and instead just tries to capture the
villain froppy then appears at this
moment
and so toga begins to retreat presumably
because she's outnumbered
as she returns to the league of villains
she begins to cry
and regrets that she didn't get the
chance to talk about love
because both her and ochako like the
same person
who is obviously this ultimate chad
right here
in the final page we get some awesome
close-ups of shigaraki's face
of ida najere endeavour deku
derby shoto and gigantomachia
endeavor and deku look really beaten up
in their close-ups
like they're not going to be active
anytime soon whereas debbie's close-up
was quite funny in that
he was practicing his best i want to
call it a pretty boy pose
something like that like he's in a boy
band or something i don't know it looked
really funny
you'll see it when the chapter comes out
it's interesting to note that the
caption at the end of this chapter
says the war is reaching its finale so
it's interesting that it goes out his
way to specify that
i guess things really are about to end
and as soon as dabi reaches the
battlefield and you know gives his big
speech and does his plan
then yeah it might be over so i reckon
by the end of november
this whole thing should be wrapped up
and we'll get some clear ideas of
how things are also for those of you who
may have been wondering about the
strange title of this chapter it means a
frank person
and a secretive person which is
referencing how toga is literally just
telling a track of everything whereas
ochako wasn't really giving too much
away
anyway that was the spoiler review for
this week make sure to turn on
notifications so you don't miss the chat
to review
and i also have a theory dropping
tomorrow that you probably don't want to
miss
until then peace out